kind of a joke but kind of you know i
have to bring it up at what age did you
decide you wanted to be the youngest
egot winner
he got wasn't even a thing until like
30 rock popularized it uh in the early
aughts right you know and to chase
something that tracy morgan is chasing
is nuts um
but you know for me
um
you know it's again like i i think about
like stats right like i was just
watching the australian open and it was
amazing to watch
rafa nadal like get the 21st open but he
wasn't thinking about that he was
thinking this guy half my age is hitting
a ball at me very fast
you know so a lot of what you're doing
is just making stuff because
you're making it for the sake of making
it you hope it connects um and then this
but the stats that come out um they're
interesting and they're cool but they're
never what you're chasing
i i understand by the way if i could
vote for you i would stuff the ballot
box with like a thousand votes you know
just
just to help that along um what does it
mean to you for the dga to be talking
about giving you i believe it's called
the outstanding directorial achievement
of a first-time feature film director
first of all the company
i'm in is just incredible because
rebecca made such a beautiful movie
maggie gyllenhaal made such an
incredible movie so it's just it's
really cool company to be in um but but
also this is this was my first love i
wanted to be i used to say i wanted to
be steven spielberg when i grew up
before i even understood what he did i
just knew his names were on the movies i
liked um and he was synonymous with
directing and that's what i wanted to do
so it's it just feels like a really
lovely vote of confidence from from
these people i really admire
i know that generally netflix doesn't
release their stuff on blu-ray it's very
rare have you guys talked about
releasing tic tick boom on blu-ray and
including like a whole bunch of extras
that perhaps
aren't seen because you know netflix
doesn't really offer extras online
yeah no i um we haven't talked about
blu-ray specifically but we have talked
about releasing the stuff um so you know
to that end we've released a lot of our
vfx passes we were able to um the the
internet was uh very adamant uh that we
released sextet which is a montage
sequence um in our movie again i just
thought well this is like not a whole
song it's really a phrase that we kind
of keep introducing but the internet
wanted to have it so we gave it to them
um and and so yeah i mean i think
eventually it will all be released
online but we haven't had blu-ray
conversations about it i would imagine
after you demonstrating what you can do
with tick tick boom
that a lot of people wanted to meet with
you to talk about directing other things
what has it been like having people want
to talk to you about directing other
movies because i would imagine that as
someone who grew up wanting to you know
it has to be amazing
yeah it's it's really thrilling um the
other thing i
learned in this experience is it has you
have to care so much about it because
it's your entire life um you know you
you dream decisions
when you're directing a movie because
there are more decisions um that you
know you're the last person to make them
um across all departments um so
um it has to be something you're really
uh passionate about i was so
lucky that julio had the idea to make
tiktik boom into a film um because
as soon as she said it to me i was like
i understand how to make that and and i
don't know that that's the case with
everything i think you have to
understand
um that you you can bring something to
it and because i
am a musical theater songwriter because
i jonathan larson is one of the people
who inspired me to write in the first
place i i felt like i innately
understood
how to unlock this um
and
what it also gave me was a flavor for
what kind of stuff i would want to
direct i um
um i love to make more little musicals
um you know i think we think of musicals
as this binary thing they're big splashy
hollywood musicals or they're not
musicals like in in the popular
imagination and one of the great gifts
of this past year was the diversity of
musicals on display you know the
musicals can be annette the musicals can
be cyrano they can be tiktik boom they
can be everybody's talking about jaime
those are all really different movies
and they're all musicals so um i would
love to continue to kind of
kick at the borders of what people think
a musical film is and could be
i would love to see you doing this um so
i would imagine every day of your life
someone wants to talk to you about
hamilton and that must be awesome and
that's great but what is it like to all
of a sudden transition to every single
day people want to talk to you about
encanto
uh it's an absolute gift right you know
i
i think that um
you cannot
control the success
of a thing it's like it you throw it out
into the world and it lands on the wave
or it doesn't or it gets rediscovered
many years later and
um and the fact that you know encanto
opened and it was fine and it did well
um and then like
people just kind of kept going back to
bruno and then rediscovering the entire
soundtrack and the fact that every song
on the soundtrack is on the charts right
now is mind-blowing to me um but it also
what's so funny is the thing that
let me put this how do i put this the
right way the thing that is the
trickiest
is the reason for it like
there were so many times when they were
like you're gonna have to cut some
characters that's a lot of characters
for a disney movie um you know and that
happens so much right like you cut away
uh anyone who isn't the main character
and what's their obstacles and their
goals and at the outset we said we want
to tell an intergenerational latino
family story
and as much complexity as we can get
into 90 minutes as we can and the
dynamics are the story um that is what
the story is is like
them seeing each other more fully and as
a result of that there's so many inroads
for folks there's people see beings
feeling seen by luisa's song and surface
pressure
there's uh people who feel like bruno
who they're the family member everyone
talks around instead of two directly um
and it's given folks a vocabulary for
talking about their family dynamics in a
way that is like safe and healing
because it's not about them it's like
you see that that's how i feel um in the
same way inside out did you know like
who's at the wheel is it anger or is it
hunger is it joy um and and that's
really thrilling because that was the
trickiest obstacle for us and i think
it's also a part of
what keeps folks coming back to it
because they they notice bruno jamming
in the corner during dolores verse
uh i know you love disney animated
movies i know that they really impacted
your life what does it mean to be
nominated for an oscar for your work in
a disney animated movie
it uh i
i literally fell in love with the oscars
because of disney animated movies i was
ride or die for the little mermaid um
that was my favorite movie in my young
life and i watched the oscars for the
first time that year because if
kiss the girl or under the seat didn't
win i was ready to riot as a
nine-year-old
and um and then as a result you get to
watch the oscars and billy crystal
does this amazing job as a host and
it became my
entry into a world of movies that just
aren't offered to kids i remember
falling in love with
like akira kurosawa because he got a
lifetime achievement award at the oscars
and then i went to the library to go
take out the two cassette seven samurai
uh from the new york public library and
falling in love with his work on my own
terms became this kind of like entry
point into a wider world for me um so
uh the fact that you know i'm here with
the disney song is wildly full circle
for me because that's the reason i tuned
in in the first place
i know that with you can only i think
i'm wrong i think i'm right about this i
just want to make sure i believe that
the studio can only submit one song or
how does it work in terms of deciding
what song would be submitted can you
submit multiple songs can you explain
ironically it's an allen menken rule
alan lincoln was running the table so
hardcore with his when he ushered in the
second age of of animation at uh at
disney with howard ashman that i think
for beauty and the beast three of the
five nominees were from beauty and the
beast and then they i think they
captured it too
thanks to ashman and menken um and then
most folks submit one song so you're not
competing with yourself um and and so
you know with the logic for us
um submitting those
is
you you don't know what the success or
failure of the soundtrack is going to be
and we had the luxury of like we like
all our songs so the goal is
what's the song that encapsulates the
spirit of the movie um and and for me
dosorovitas does that beautifully uh so
that's that's what we submitted but god
i remember with moana it was like how
far i'll go and you're welcome
and
it's like well
the if we get nominated the rock might
sing on the oscars
but how far i'll go really is what moana
is all about so that's that's what you
submit
uh
i believe we don't talk about bruno is
the one i wrote this down the first
disney song since aladdin's a whole new
world to top the billboard 100 which is
part of my language f and crazy um
like crazy what does that actually mean
to you that it's permeated to you know
what i mean everyone is listening to
this
but but like it's like straight up crazy
because
it's
an ensemble number
with characters that are not really the
main character each getting solos they
overlap
and you kind of have to have seen the
movie to really understand what's going
on so it's just like the least likely
candidate for breakout success
possible i couldn't have engineered
a more unlikely uh success but again
it gets back to the biggest obstacle in
this movie was
hanging on to as many of these
characters as possible and revealing
them to each other in interesting new
ways i pitched this song as a proof of
concept that we could hold them all
because i said if we do a gossip number
we can hear from the other characters
who aren't going to get their own solos
i can write a dolores verse i can write
a camino verse and we can hear what
their musical voices sound like without
devoting the real estate of an entire
tune to them that was literally the
pitch um and the side result of that is
you've got
camilo stands and you've got dolores
stands um and and it became actually
this on-ramp for for all these different
folks everyone has a different part it's
um
a karaoke number where everyone gets to
it becomes an all skate um so it's uh
again it's and i'm so thrilled and
happily surprised by it but it also
it it makes people want to watch the
movie so they can understand what the
song's about um there are a lot of
reddit threads on encanto a lot of
people online debating little easter
eggs and secret things in the movie have
you heard or seen any wild theories
about encanto that you're like oh wow
that that's true i didn't even realize
it well i mean honestly the detail of
bruno dancing in the background of
dolores verse is not one i noticed until
someone pointed it out to me on the
internet and now i cannot see it um
but yeah again it's it
it's really fun for me because
the
i watched that development process i i
was there when
you know the powers were all swapped and
peppa piti peppa was indestructible and
um you know mirabelle's mom
mood controlled the weather um so i was
kind of there as the mythology was being
built and jared and charisse and byron
were figuring out
how to make the gifts the extensions of
of these characters and how we were
going to tell
this story and
and
the delight in people having theories in
oh well mirabella is going to take over
her gift is going to be she's going to
be the head of the family in the same
way that abuela who doesn't have a gift
is the head of the fan like that's all
fair game and it's all
uh wonderful it's all really again
because we have so many characters
there's just a lot to unpack i would
imagine with the success of the
soundtrack that disney maybe has reached
out to you and said hey um do you want
to release any songs that like alternate
versions of the songs or deleted songs
or is that stuff that
you don't want to have see the light of
day or is that stuff that you sort of
want to share after a certain point like
how you and i mean because there's so
many it's interesting because
there aren't that many this was a pretty
quick ascent up the mountain um in terms
of the development
um the only cut songs i really have
they're all cut mirabelle i want songs
because the iwant song is the hardest
song to write uh in any movie i
struggled with it the most on moana with
how far i'll go i struggled with it the
most here for two reasons one um
you have to really understand what the
journey is to be able to then go
backwards and write
what the main character really wants and
needs um and and so often uh and those
things really have to to line up for us
to feel uh satisfied um and then the
other thing is like it's just
intimidating because disney has the best
i want songs
you've got part of your world and colors
of the wind and let it go
and into the unknown and
reflection um
day right you know it's it's just an
intimidating legacy so it's always it's
not enough to
get the assignment right of what does
this character want it has to soar in a
really specific way and um
and you know if it doesn't pass the test
of a kid like singing with a hairbrush
in the mirror um like it doesn't win and
i i actually that was um a moment where
i called bobby and kristen you know i'm
very lucky to count them among my
friends and said you know i'm lyrically
it's here but i want it to do this and
i'm not i don't have my and they were an
incredible sounding board for me uh in
that number so the answer to your
question is like there's not really much
to share
because the songs that i wrote are
essentially in the movie with the
exception of like two or three cut
mirabelle stabs
i put on twitter that i was going to
talk to you and something that came up
with a number of people was
did you record demos yourself of all the
songs and would you ever consider
sharing them so people can hear them
yeah um yeah that's that's how i write i
i play piano i work on this very
computer and i make myself uh demos um
there's a kid on tick tock who does an
incredible impression of me and he's
basically done like what this would
sound like as a demo
and he's ursula man that kid stole my
voice he sounds just like me
so like the answer's like you kind of
already have them uh because that's what
they sound like so i i forgive me i
don't know the the kid's name but like
you got him like
you don't need to hear mine like it's
already out there that kid's
devastatingly accurate i think there's
something to your name being on it
though um not not everyone is on tick
tock just throwing that out there i'm
sure disney would like it but speaking
of disney with the success of the movie
is there um have you had like a
conversation with them where they're
like sort of saying to you do you have
ideas for what like a spin-off for
disney plus is there something else we
can explore in this universe that you're
interested in or do you know what i mean
yeah well i listen i do think
um
there's an appetite to further explore
the madrigal family given how many
characters there are and how many gifts
there are um and also where we leave the
story right like oh now there is sort of
um this more fully realized version of
themselves which which way can we go i
think it's going to be a question i
think it's a question of
when and not if um and what form that
we'll take is that another movie is that
a series is that a
stage adaptation where we have a little
more time because stage shows are
generally an hour longer than movies um
you know and we haven't had
conversations as to what form that we'll
take um but
uh
i mean yeah i'd be down to continue to
explore that i love writing for
dolores and camilo i'd love to write
more for them i'd love to write more for
um isabella so i'm not sure what the
next form of that uh will be but we
haven't had specific conversations about
it's this or it's this
i didn't even think until you said it
the idea of an encanto stage show like
on broadway but oh my god people would
love that yeah well again it's and i
think part of that is the success of the
film itself you know jamal and kai did
such incredible choreography on the
characters in a way that we don't often
see in an animated musical like they're
doing moves that we can do
um and you know i think of dolores
little shimmy uh in her verse or the way
they they're setting the table and
dancing at the same time you know that's
the animators being inspired by their
incredible work and i think that fires
people's imaginations up of like oh i
could see this on stage um so you know
if if that's
the way it goes like
like great um you know it's uh again
right now we're just all enjoying
you know i have a group thread with the
filmmakers and you know we're just
sending
memes and videos and
like everything you guys are making we
are we are enjoying like the the
feedback loop of the way people uh have
have embraced this film
last question for you um you've been
very prolific the last few years in
terms of all these movies you've been
working on all these different things
what is the horizon looking like for you
now that these projects have wrapped
have you been sort of like secretly
working on all these other things that
we don't know about or is it sort of
like you you're taking a little bit of
like looking at the horizon deciding
what do i next want to do
yeah it's interesting because i think
the world experienced it as this
prolificness but in the heights took 13
years from broadway to the big screen um
vivo was 11 and tik-tik boom and
engentil were kind of my opposing muscle
groups at five years each
and so
i have a really clear horizon line
honestly and
what i kind of want to do
for this next little bit is just refill
my cup um put myself in a situation
where i'm a student again i've been i've
been reaching out to songwriters i
admire just saying can i hang while
you're writing um
i think i've
developed um
a style uh from having
you know written so much for so long and
people can identify uh what i sound like
at the piano and um
my next goal is to just like totally get
out of that and attack the like learn
from other songwriters attack it from
any direction so the next piece you go
he wrote that that doesn't sound
anything like him um again i'm i'm
inspired and heartbroken by stephen
sondheim's passing as everyone else and
one of the the great lessons of his life
was
you know to go in the other direction um
when they're expecting this from you and
uh you know in a lot of ways hamilton
was a reaction to in the heights like no
one was expecting that from that and i
don't know what the new direction is yet
so i'm going to read some books and
listen to music and and try to learn
from from artists i admire on that note
i really want to say a sincere again
thank you for everything you're doing
and the congrats on encanto and the
nomination and um i wish you nothing but
the best
thank you thank you always good to talk
to you
you